foreign
I've developed a really big crush on a
co-worker I feel like I'm back in high
school and it's uh I've been happily
married for almost four years my
marriage is great and I don't know why
all of a sudden this has come up but it
has are you ready just to buckle up
because I got a lot of thoughts
[Music]
it's that time again to Dr John
deloney's show I'm John so glad that
you're with us
talking about mental health and marriage
and parenting and falling apart what in
the world hope you're doing well if you
want to be on the show give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 and we will rock on to
the break it down let's go to Brandon in
Phoenix what's up Brandon
hi John how are you remarkable how are
you
doing well doing well thanks for taking
my call you got it man what's up
uh so kind of a a weird situation
um my wife and I recently moved here to
Phoenix a few months ago I started a
brand new job
um totally new city New State all of
that
um and over the past month month and a
half or so
uh I've developed a really big crush on
a co-worker
and I feel like I'm yeah
yeah
I feel like I'm back in high school and
it's the it's a very weird feeling uh
I've been happily married for almost
four years and uh my marriage is great
and I don't know why all of a sudden
this has come up but it has and I'm not
sure how to navigate that
um
Okay so
are you ready just to buckle up because
I got a lot of thoughts
okay here's your job your job is to
interrupt me at any point okay
okay is that cool
that's cool I'm gonna rock and roll you
tell me you're wrong hold on and just
yell throw a flag or if you have like
one of those shut up buttons just push
it okay
so sounds good four years in
y'all have started to settle in and then
you took a new job you all moved to a
new town it was exciting and scary and
y'all had to leave friends or family or
whatever and you landed here okay and
your wife has probably settled into
you're developing a routine you're
starting to talk about what house one
day and maybe having kids or we're not
gonna have kids and all that stuff and
you're slowly slowly tiny slowly
feeling the old adventurous yeah dude
Brandon
slow you're starting to suffocate a
little bit and the humanity of your wife
is real she's got boogers and she farts
and she's like doesn't wear makeup all
the time like all that stuff
and
then you start this new job in this new
town
and somebody makes your heart start
beating a little faster again and maybe
her body's a little bit better than your
wives a little bit different I don't say
better then but it's more your jam or
maybe there's something in the way she
touches your arm or she laughs or she
listens to the same music as you there's
a little thing
that slowly makes you feel like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I remember this guy
the way he used to feel around girls
like her and you even said it
uh you feel like a high schooler again
you know it was in high school for some
of us like me I loved it
I love the awkwardness I love wondering
if she liked me I wondered I loved when
she broke up with me I mean I hate it at
the time but in retrospect I loved my
wife hated it I loved it dude and so let
me make this super clear to you okay
this is not about her
nothing to do with her this is about you
and I want to free you from something
being attracted to people thinking
people are awesome wondering what if I
would even go as far as to say is having
like a crush on so like I just like
spending time with it that's the rest of
your life dude and I'm not I I think
anybody who beats you up over that is an
idiot okay
um okay but
yeah let me say this but you're always
going to find people that are sexy or
beautiful hilarious fun I had one friend
tell me um he ended up leaving his wife
right so and we'll get to that in a
second
but he said something I Just Like the
Way She Moves
and there was a sensuality to a way this
this person he worked with the way she
just moved through the world right it
wasn't even this particular I'm
overwhelmed by how beautiful she is or
whatever whatever
so whatever that is you land on two
choices okay you ready
Choice number one
I am going to scratch and fight and Claw
my way back to feeling alive inside the
marriage that I committed my life to
and we'll talk about that in a second
how you do that but we're going to
create a world where I feel alive where
I'm daily leaning into my wife where I
tell her the truth where I tell her what
I would love to try in the bedroom what
I would like to stop doing like when it
comes to holiday plans all that stuff
I'm gonna start telling her the truth
because I haven't really been I've been
hoping she's a mind reader and kind of
leaning in a little bit and hoping she
would pretend and kind of trying to
position her this way but I haven't said
anything because I'm kind of dishonest
and kind of a coward a little bit and
I'm gonna allow her to say the same
thing too I'm gonna respect her
boundaries
so I'm going to stop there before I get
to number two am I off by on any of this
no uh actually just kind of describing
the situation you you've pretty much
nailed it on the head and and I I want
to clarify yeah like I'm I'm in a great
marriage I love my wife uh but yeah I
think I don't know just something about
starting in this new place and uh and I
don't even have that that close of a
relationship with this co-worker it's
literally just being friends at work but
uh yeah she's this co-worker definitely
has me feeling some of those things so
okay I think I think you're right on so
that leads me to number two
okay you're gonna respect the fact that
you stood up
in front of your friends and your family
and if you're a person of faith in front
of God
and you stood before her
your wife
and you said come what comes I will be
right here
yeah what that means is
when you have crushes and want to hang
out more and want to have a little side
text conversation with somebody
I have been there across the board on
all those things dude and I've
accidentally
through private jokes and thinking this
is funny found myself staring over an
abyss
with no intention see what I'm saying
yeah I think God I've never done
anything irreversible but I'm telling
you it's just so innocuous and my whole
life
was about flirty energy that's how he
entered a room
and I'm telling you right now it's it's
been an off switch now I enter a room
with peace and I don't want anything
from any of the people because what I
realized I was using people to make
myself feel better okay so the earlier
you can say
yeah she's beautiful
she's hilarious and I'd like to there it
is that's when you got a choice
I don't I just don't I don't text women
I'm not married to I don't go get drinks
with fill in the blank anymore I don't
do this anymore I make sure I sit over
here
because I told my wife
and it's gonna feel like
um
I mean gosh now you're gonna get me all
so boxed out we just live in a culture
that's just like your feelings are the
most important thing and I reject that
with all of my heart
because you have the same feelings that
point out how much how pretty she is and
how funny she is or whatever that you're
finding attractive about her
those same feelings pointed you towards
your wife like feelings are feelings and
then you made a choice right and so
action I think is really critical here
um okay
[Music]
what are you gonna do
well I I I have been meaning to really
talk about it with my wife I'm a little
nervous as to how she'll react what
would that bring you
um well I mean I I think for me it would
bring me peace but yeah I'm I am a
little anxious as to what she'll have
you done anything have you done anything
wrong
no
what is man now I'm gonna get myself in
some dangerous territory
what I've found with younger Millennials
is uh and it's it's a Rel and I say that
not in a disparaging way I just don't
see it in other other generational
groups is a need to over over share
an almost weaponized transparency
what I mean by that is
um
I tell people all the time you can't
keep secrets like you gotta be honest
with your spouse you got to tell what's
going on you got to tell them like all
that's good and I'm finding people who
are 22 23 25 26 walking down the mall
and looking over at their husband and
being like man I'd like to sleep with
that guy and it's like that's super not
helpful right there's a point when it's
it so that's what I'm asking you what
what about this situation you're at a
new job in a new town in a new place
maybe you didn't want to take this new
job maybe this is mostly the house that
your wife picked maybe you're starting
to settle in and say oh my gosh this is
the rest of my life and I don't like who
I'm becoming and then I see her
what makes you say I need to go tell my
wife that I found somebody else
attractive
you could be transparent with my wife uh
you know I've always been and um I yeah
I guess I'm just afraid of maybe you
know triggering some anxiety some
jealousy in her
um will you ever cheat on your wife
sorry will you ever cheat on your wife
no okay
if I was you I would probably I would
consider a couple of things one yes if I
mean you know your marriage better than
me if sitting down saying I need you to
know that I have feelings for somebody
at work and I don't even hear you saying
you have feelings for somebody I have
you I feel like you're telling or I hear
you telling me
I'm kind of caught off guard because I'm
kind of caught a crush on somebody which
is different than I I really I'm trying
to figure out ways to spend more time
with somebody I really want somebody
else does that make sense and it sounds
like I'm being I'm dancing a fine line
here but if you tell me if I'm wrong
yeah
um
let me give you this picture Esther
perel paints and I love it
you spend all of your dating time
practicing safety
is she gonna show up is he gonna answer
the phone
if somebody tries to like get me in a
bar is he gonna stand up for me like
we're practicing safety
and you're LED all with desire can't
wait to be together you blow off tests
you skip work you're making out in the
middle of dinner like right I mean it's
it's all about desire
then when you begin to establish safety
it's very difficult for desire to remain
in the presence of safety
right that's uh that's that's settling
in
what we don't have in our culture we do
have the practice safety you'll hear
your friends being like hey do you does
does he call you back does did she
listen to you and you were telling her
that you were sad like we have those
conversations we don't have the other
conversations which are
how do I create a world where we're both
Fully Alive and there's mystery and
romance and all-day text exchanges that
lead into firework shows right and right
you see what I'm saying so
I think the best way to start this
conversation is we just started a whole
new life in a new town with a new job
and I find myself on a trajectory where
I don't like who I'm becoming
and my guess is it's not just related to
this person at work that you feel like a
high schooler around
my guess is you're probably also
avoiding X not helping around the house
a little bit maybe taking one more drink
than you normally do or eating one more
Taco than you normally do am I wrong on
any of those
um I I wouldn't say I'm I I I've
actually been really trying to work on
myself better just hitting the gym more
and things like that
um and right there's the challenge can I
tell you that I know that I know I'm
going against everything that you're
going to see on Instagram for the next
five months I know that
when you all lock into a new town in a
new place and a new adventure in a new
part of your life
you each going your separate ways to
quote unquote work on yourselves can
actually pull you all further apart
you may end up spending more time in the
gym but the only way this thing works
long term is if you all decide we're
doubling down on who we're going to be
together
right and so your whole life is
different and you'll probably have not
called that out yet
your old marriage is over your old
College time is over your old high
school time is over you're on a new town
in a new state and a new job and a new
whatever
and so
you all have to acknowledge we're
building a new world
and right part of our new world is we
take care of ourselves cool I need to go
to the gym see what I'm see how
different that is than I've been working
on myself listening to podcasts going to
the gym
um do it like journaling more all of
those things are isolating you further
and further and further from the person
that you're supposed to be building a
life with
okay yeah
and you may end up doing those same
things I hope I don't sound crazy you
may end up doing those same exact things
but they're going to be in service to
your marriage not in service to you just
getting better so you can crush and kill
and I'm I'm becoming more and more
outspoken I think we've just missed it
as a culture
um Brandon I'm not I'm not picking on
you now I'm just talking to everybody
somewhere along the way we begin telling
people you shouldn't be married you
shouldn't get in relationships until
you're all you and if you're struggling
with like a mental health disorder or
you've got some major personality
challenges yes you need to go make sure
you're well
or if you're codependent marrying
somebody so that you can be okay is
never healthy but this idea that I've
got to go be a Spartan and you've got to
be a Spartan so that we can then get
married as Madness
you got to do that stuff together in
service of one another I'm not going to
crush it and kill it in my 20s so I can
crush it and killed it in my so I can
have crushing kill in my 20s I'm gonna
crush it and kill it in my 20s
because me and my wife have a vision of
what our family tree is going to look
like when the dust settles on our life
and I'm willing to put all that work in
I'm willing to do this and x and y and
sacrifice on behalf of my wife and my
kids and my community and my country and
my wife is I'm I'm willing to put this
aside and this aside and that goes right
in the face of you follow your dreams
and you follow your dreams when somebody
tells me these words it's the new magic
words
um
our marriage just ran its course
bullcrap I call BS I called BS
one of you quit or what both of you quit
or one of you did something that the
other person said I can no longer be a
part of this
but the idea that a relationship just
naturally runs out of gas is false
people make life changes people move
people make decisions about how they're
going to invest in themselves and other
people and and more importantly in the
total relationship so Brandon I tell you
all have to tell you
I love you you're not crazy I don't
think you're a bad guy I don't think you
need to walk in your front door and be
like I am
I I don't I I don't hear that okay I
also you you if you listen to the show
for five seconds you know I'm really
anti-secrets right it may be that when
you tell your wife hey I'm even finding
myself like having crushes on people at
work like I I I'm worried about
um I'm worried about my trajectory
and I want to create a world where we
desire one another
um and we practice desire on a regular
basis
um
I want you to know you're not crazy
I've been there I don't know actually uh
anybody that hasn't been there male or
female quite honestly
[Music]
question is what are you gonna do
are you gonna do what the culture says
and follow your feelings
and they're gonna lead you right off a
cliff
or are you gonna remember I made a
covenant I said till death do us part
all my things are your things and all
your things are my things and I'll spend
the rest of my life making sure your
life is well and I hope you'll do the
same for me
I think you should choose option two
but that's just me we'll be right back
I've got a word from our sponsor
betterhelp listen I've been on both ends
of therapy in my life I've gotten it
myself and I've walked people through it
and I've seen the benefits from both
sides when someone owns their past and
the cracks in their armor but here's the
deal Getting to Know Yourself is not a
one-time event acknowledging the stories
that make you who you are can be a
lifelong process and talking through
things with the right sounding board
empowers you to change your future and
be the best version of yourself so if
you're thinking about starting therapy I
recommend better help better help
connect you with a licensed therapist
who can walk with you on that journey of
self-discovery and it's a hundred
percent online and it's designed to be
convenient flexible and work for your
schedule just fill out a quick question
here to get matched with a licensed
therapist and if it's not the right fit
you can switch therapists at any time
for no additional charge visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com
deloney
all right let's go to Parker in Memphis
Tennessee what's up Parker
John freaking deloney Parker freaking
Parker what's up dude
I don't know if your last name is
your last name Parker too please
yes this is the best part okay
okay hold on dude I keep interrupting
you what'd you say
I said I can't believe I'm talking to
the best mental health expert on the
best mental health podcast ever
yes okay so real quick clarification I'm
not even close to the best mental health
professional but this is the best show
right I'm not even the top 200 dude not
top 2000 I'm not very good come on man
give yourself but we got a dope podcast
all right make sure you talk uh directly
into your phone
um okay so what's up life all right
yeah it's good I practiced that intro
like 20 times and apparently my phone
cut out so that's good all right do it
again
I can't believe I'm talking to the
greatest mental health expert on the
greatest mental health podcast ever dude
so we established this earlier but I'll
say it again
um
I I'm not really good at being a mental
health expert I'm not very good but this
is the greatest show of all time ever
you did nail that one yeah so yeah so
what's up Parker how can I help hey real
quick what boats are you in jiu jitsu oh
dude I was trained by a guy who did all
his training in Japan and then my other
coach was from mainland China both of
them believed that belts were for
American kids to feel good about
themselves into past anyway they had a
whole thing against belts so no belts
for me dude
okay now I've never heard that before
that's awesome well I mean it would be
really cool if I had a belt hanging from
but I would have been not very far along
I got you I got so cool but in my heart
super black belt dude no sir 100 man yes
so what's up okay so my question is man
um
did I set my son up for a life of
anxiety yeah um I'll give you a
backstory okay
um when I was about you know 11 or 12 I
had like
these big big dreams of being like uh in
the UFC doing MMA and all that stuff
and um if I start rambling just let me
know just interrupt me have you ever
have you ever listened to the show
before
I have yeah yeah yeah I ramble a lot
natural Rambler too so there you go
you're in good company all right go for
it
all right so like all my life I have
these dreams of being this uh the next
Conor McGregor or Michael Chandler or
something like that and um
to be honest I I've done martial arts my
whole life and
um
I started to get distracted I had a I
got a wife I got married and I had a kid
and when I had my first kid I was like I
didn't really try hard enough to do this
MMA thing so I'm gonna try it
and so I accumulated a record of like
three and two which is not you know not
amazing but it's uh I had potential and
then I got my then I had a second kid
and um around that time I decided I was
like I don't think I need to get get
punched in the face all the time and not
get paid for it so
I decided to quit the quit the you know
pursuit of MMA and
when that happened I I started I felt
this hole in my heart where martial arts
had been my whole life
and so I started started filling that
with alcohol
and it was kind of like a
kind of a slow start you're losing a
one-two drinks here or there and then it
turned into every weekend
and then it turned into like
every time every you know every time I
was awake I was either buzzed or had
anxiety
and um
my now five-year-old he was you know he
was in for all of that and so I became
you know very I became like a ticking
Time Bomb I was
um
just always yelling always screaming I
was kind of just like you said in your
book Radioactive
and um
at the beginning of 2022 I decided to
really you know get control of my life
back
um I've lost about 40 pounds I stopped
drinking and
um really started you know working on
myself thought it could be better for my
family
and then a couple of days ago I was on I
was on Tick Tock and uh I saw this Mel
Robbins interviewed with a
neuroscientist that said um
80 of your
um 80 of your childhood development
starts at like between zero and five
years old and
man I almost dropped my phone because I
was like
I was
such a such a hot head such a
such a radioactive person between his
zero and five
and so my question to you is did I set
him up for a life of anxiety and if I
did what can I do to you know help him
navigate through his life yeah that's a
great question man thanks for telling
that story I wasn't rambling at all that
was I was really good man uh okay cool
and we track a lot
um
some of my story is very similar I got
into the reason I got into mixed martial
arts initially
was because I ran my mouth so much
and I always found myself every time I
went out with my buddies every time I
played a pickup basketball game and I
had friends that were nuts and they
loved fighting and so I found myself
a disconnect between how much I ran my
mouth and what I knew deep down I was
not capable of doing
and so I went
I began my journey there
really
um to wallpaper over a very insecure
little boy that had now suddenly found
himself inside of a man's body
and my dreams I never dreamed of being
professional I was never I was never the
thing I liked going to the gym every
night with I think at one point the
state kickboxing heavyweight champion
was there the light heavyweight champion
was there some just some Killers man and
then when the China won the Olympics and
they started running through San shoo
Fighters it was I mean some of the
craziest athletes in the world and it
was awesome
and I felt myself transitioned from this
scared little boy who was trying to Bow
up and show everybody
to
um
the most peaceful calm guy I could
possibly be and so I I'm a firm believer
my my kids are getting involved in it
soon like I'm a firm believer in martial
arts over the Long Haul because I think
it takes some of that nonsense out of
you
so the first thing I would ask you is
this is a private conversation for you
and yourself
was any of that dream any of that
lifelong journey in mixed martial arts
and martial arts was any of that a way
to run from something you thought you
were not it might not be but I think
this it wasn't okay
um that's where I would start because
that that was for me
I
here's the uh um
here's a challenge scientists face
many things can be true at the same time
and it's very hard to digest that in the
public
and so while what Mel Robbins and the
neuroscientists said is accurate
an unfathomable a fathomable amount of
neurodevelopment happens from zero to
five
tons and tons and tons of I mean your
brain is literally growing itself you
may have heard this but
um
really the first 18 months of a kid's
life is really considered the Third
I mean the fourth trimester you can't
really have a trimester but
um the the brain's not done developing
yet babe humans just have their babies
early and so all that to say is that's
true and
genetic dispositions are true and none
of that is causal none of that is
deterministic
that's also true
and what that means is
when somebody is as loving and wise as
you
who's able to go whoa I don't like the
set of train tracks I'm on
the beauty is a there's messages like
that that get your attention and B there
is light and hope in the next set of
train tracks you put you and your family
on
yeah so I want you to sleep well at
night now I'll be totally honest with
you if you keep going the same way
you've been going absolutely your kid's
gonna reflect your
um
angst your rage it being uh the child of
an alcoholic is evil dude because you're
there in per in in body but you're not
there in person and spirit
um and a kid feels lost right so all
that's true you do nothing yes
so I'm gonna tell you what just happened
at my house okay this is me just being
vulnerable to you
yeah
um I and this is it's it's a shameful
thing for me because I do this for a
living okay and it's so cool to talk to
people about their parents and their
marriage and their kids and all that and
then I got parents and I'm married and I
got kids and so I get to live at home
and see if this actually works or not
so
um
I had a really gnarly interaction with
my daughter
she just I'm probably getting choked up
here
um
she she wouldn't let me tuck her in at
night she just said no and to the point
that she was screaming and crying like
it was a big mess and at first I was
just trying to get my wife a night off
or two nights off for three nights off
and then I was like hey I just want to
hug my daughter
and she's she's seven she wouldn't do it
and then it became like for after
breakfast before she went to school like
they can have a hug before you go to
school and she would just look at me and
walk away and then my inner Texas male
was like that's disrespectful and I'm
this and you need to
like I'm your father like that all that
stuff right yeah
and
I call a buddy of mine's a counselor and
she gave me some good wisdom and then my
wife said something that was really
powerful
um and it reminded me back of a Gabor
mate book that I read and that's that's
I think one of the most important uh
books ever written about parenting it's
called hold on to your kids
but here's what he says
be likable
and maybe your seven-year-old little
girl doesn't not like her dad in fact
she loves him deeply but she feels that
energy on off his like pulsing out of
you
and suddenly I wrote about it in the
book I realized oh crap I've become old
me again
I'm a nuclear reactor I'm always hot I'm
always coming in late I'm always flying
around the place I'm always just right
on edge right on edge right on edge
and I'm gonna tell you this dude
um I went and at the same time I had a
boss uh someone I work with tell me that
I'm really hard to be friends with not
because I'm not a nice guy I tell the
truth all that I'm just a lot I just
overwhelm people
um all the time
so then I did something that the Texas
male and me never thought would happen
and I decided I'm gonna try to be really
likable and what that meant was I had to
be very peaceful and what that meant was
I just start just changing the way I
experienced the world the way I thought
about things what I did what I ate how
much I slept all that stuff
you know this morning
get choked up
this morning my wife had to peel my
daughter off of me because we were
having a hug-off competition
okay
so I want you to have peace in your soul
it can change
what you're going to want to do is come
up with a program or what are the 10
steps too and I don't think that's the
map back to a kid's heart to a
non-anxious kid
what you're gonna have to do is decide I
want to have a non-anxious life I want
to be not anxious house
that means we gotta own reality that
means we got to choose Freedom We're Not
Gonna owe people money we're not gonna
be like you're gonna set yourself up in
a position over the next three to five
years where you can quit at any time
a job if you've got a toxic boss or
somebody asking you to do something you
don't want to do you're going to take
care of your body y'all are going to get
connected to something bigger than
yourself you're going to practice
mindfulness you're going to create a
non-anxious life for yourself
and your kids will become that
I believe that with all my heart
yeah and that's that's what I've been
working on this year or this on 2022 was
you know trying to my best to live an
unacious life it's it's difficult but
it's real hard it's real hard okay and I
know that
um
I want to challenge you in a couple of
things okay I'm going to give you a
couple things I want you to try with
your kid and I'm gonna challenge you on
a couple things and I'm gonna give you
some tools I'll put my money where my
mouth is okay
um I want you with your five-year-old to
start a journal with him on his bed just
go to Walgreens and buy like a crappy
spiral
and it might be a picture
of daddy smiling and with an over I want
you to draw like an over like the smile
extra big
no it might be like a heart
and just put on his pillow and his job
is to write to you before he goes to
school the next day
and color in it or whatever that looks
like okay I want you to start that
practice the second one is
really practice just being around them
let them know that you like them
every moment is not a teaching moment
every second is not out life lesson
everything is not like uh hey you need
to pick this up why are you doing like
that you need to dry off why are you
doing that are you gonna wear deodorant
like he's only five I know yeah
um
it's like just like being around your
kid yes there's some things you got to
tell them to do but
if you get angry which you will if you
don't get angry you should probably go
see a psychiatrist because that's not
normal
um yeah I want you to take a knee and
look your kid in the eye and say I'm
choosing anger right now and this is not
about you and I'm sorry if I scared you
I'm not sorry that I'm angry
but I'm sorry that I scared you good but
daddy's not angry at you
okay I want you to teach him there's a
difference between your anger and him
okay
um touch him on his face every single
day hold his face if you can
I told my kid when he was really little
I'm gonna hug you every day of your life
and it's going to be weird sorry but not
sorry
yeah okay
um
maybe a secret breakfast date does he go
to school yet
yeah he's in pre-k so he gets off
usually like 11 or so
if y'all had like a
I take my son to Waffle House once a
week
and it's become magic time because it'll
be nothing nothing nothing nothing
nothing and then suddenly he's like hey
Dad can we talk about something and I've
created a world where that's okay
because it happens regularly right
here's what I'm gonna do for you I'm
gonna send you um a couple of things I'm
gonna send you
the full Financial Peace University I
work here at Ramsey solutions to help
you and your family get out of debt any
money you owe anybody else we're gonna
walk I'm gonna give you the plan to get
out of debts help millions of people do
it I'm gonna give it to you for free
okay
you got to watch your lessons and you
got to do it is that fair
sure okay also I'm gonna send you my
buddy um Lane Norton's carbon app I get
no money from this it's the app I use
um to keep track of my diet nutrition
and it's been a it's a it's the best
there is okay also I'm gonna send you
the newest workout from my buddies over
at mind pump it's their Maps anabolic
program advanced okay you gotta get your
butt back in the gym
cool yes sir
um and I think a great gift you could
give your kid is to start going back to
jiu jitsu classes and not doing it
because I'm going to be Conor McGregor
but doing it because I want to be able
to roll around with my grandkids when
I'm 90.
oh yeah and I have been we've just been
uh we've been in a weird season of life
where we're in the middle of a house
renovation so it's that's eating up all
of our time but yeah I've been in the
gym
quite a bit but good well I'm going to
send you some stuff okay and um hang on
the line here and Jenna's gonna get it
to you these things I'm telling you
taking care of your body taking care of
your nutrition taking care of your
finances taking care of your calendar
um taking care of you your marriage all
those things dude create a non-anxious
household and it lets your little boys
and your second kid know
Come What May in here I'm safe
and with that guy I'm safe so everybody
listen and hear me yes
much much of your neurodevelopment
happens from zero to five I think that's
probably accurate
and
neuroplasticity is a thing that will
last with you through your lifetime
so it's never too late
to reconnect with your kids it's never
too late to reconnect with your spouse
it's never too late to reconnect with
your friends it's never too late to
reconnect with yourself
you can always get off the train tracks
that you're on
if you have to just start walking
another Direction but you can get on
another set of train tracks and head off
into Adventures unknown
you can always start again thanks for
your call my brother we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I feel
like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of what
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
ask John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right we're back let's go to Marie
in h town what's up Marie
um a whole lot but I'm hoping you can
kind of untangle it
do it just drop the big ball of yarn
here right on the desk let's untangle
[Laughter]
so a little background uh my my first
issue is this my wife
no all right go ahead first issue
so the first issue is he is in his 30s
and he does not have a driver's license
oh my God how long have you been his mom
um well we have been together since
about 2018 so that long
gross you kiss your son I know I
know
the thing he all these years like
especially um we have a kid together we
had um we had our son in 2019 while I
was pregnant I kept telling him I really
need you to get your driver's license
because I can't be the only parent
taking him to daycare to doctors
appointments and he said yeah yeah I'll
do it and he's been saying oh yeah I'll
get my driver's license
all these years and I just you know and
then have you ever played Texas Hold'em
no okay it's like a it's a poker game
yeah and uh
at some point somebody says I call
and what that means is like everybody
has to show their cards to see who wins
and every time you make these demands
he's like I call
and you do nothing yeah I know you
stoled him like his mommy and then y'all
make out and then he's like his life
just goes back the way it was
I know why in the world and I'm I'm
saying this seriously I have a smile on
my face
yeah why would he get a driver's license
you do everything
I know you have sex with him like like
there's no reason for him to do anything
yeah he doesn't have a job either does
he no he does have a job oh he does okay
yeah that brings me to a third issue but
I wasn't gonna discuss that let's do it
all
right so
um the second issue is one of the issues
actually wasn't the issue that I did
bring it up in my email
um I didn't read it I didn't see your
email so just I know no I was just just
trying to remember my email to help me
stay on track
um but the other issue is
we have you know we have a four-year-old
and you know he is he has extra needs
um he is severely autistic like
non-verbal
um very sensory seeking he has a lot
and my partner Works an overnight job he
has to get a new job
yeah I tried I've tried talking about
this but it won't work with my he has a
second job coaching Jiu Jitsu yeah
that's got to stop listen everything's
got to stop I know
I don't know how to fix it
okay
um before I start talking and I hate
going into these Waters because these
waters are uncomfortable okay and I've
been laughing having fun with you and
all that but I know this is very serious
okay yeah
before I get into the hard part of this
call
um
do you still like him
I do like it's okay if you don't it's
okay if you don't
no I do like him I enjoy our
conversations and whenever I think of
leaving I just think oh my gosh I'm
gonna hurt him so bad because he's not a
bad guy okay that's
you are sacrificing yourself on the
altar of him
and you're sacrificing your little boy
on the altar of him
yeah
so I'm asking you
do you still like him
or maybe you love him but you're so
enraged because this isn't how it's
supposed to be
I
[Applause]
I care about his feelings
he doesn't care
it feels like that no I I'm telling you
I'm telling you I hope that he does come
around to care about yours one at one
day
but the fact that he still goes to a
hobby
and has figured out a way for the hobby
to give him a little money so that he
can call it a side job
the fact that he
has not looked at the reality of Your
World he's a non-verbal son that's a
very challenging world it's challenging
because there's nothing more important
to a mom and dad to have that little kid
say I love you and
you haven't had that yet
no and it's devastating
um
well I I know I know my son loves me
though oh ABS 100 absolutely absolutely
but but there's a reality to it that
most people when they hear non-verbal
they don't understand like
it's it's not the way it's supposed it
hurts it hurts
and some people lean way in and some
people run from that
and I'm not saying it's the cause sounds
like you've married a child but all that
to say is this
you care deeply about not hurting him
I would almost be willing to bet you
care about not hurting him because it
makes you look bad
um no
I I don't think so okay
because I mean I've
there's not let me say this wait there's
not a way there's not a way you can save
yourself and him not have to change
and when grown women are married to
little boys
change feels like the end of time
The Whole World's coming down
because they've gotten their way their
whole life
and so what you have to here's the thing
would you ever leave him
I was actually strongly considering it
um our lease is up in June and uh my my
mom and my sister those are the two that
I actually only two people I can really
talk to about this they both said just
leave just leave and you know you know
we'll do it or we can to help you and
and so I've been strongly considering
leaving when the lease is up and
but I don't know how and I don't know
how to break that to him
because whenever I mentioned these
things he turns it he tries he kind of
turns it around on me like I'm somehow
wrong or
um
you know like I'm overreacting
to something like a there's a there's an
additional piece to the driver's license
thing and you're going to and you're
going to hit me I already know I won't
hit you
tell me so
um he actually bought a car before we
before we got together
um he bought it cash from his friend's
mom oh God and then he never registered
it and he couldn't because he didn't
have a driver's license and then fast
forward my car was in the shop I needed
to I needed something to drive so I said
I'll just drive your car if I had to go
register it but I couldn't
um
he couldn't register it because he
didn't have a license so I registered it
under my name and his name and because
I'm the only licensed driver I put
insurance on it because I couldn't
register it otherwise
and so now you know my my car is fixed
and he's driving around this car without
a driver's license using my insurance
and my insurance already told me they
wouldn't cover if there was an accident
and we're in an area where there are a
lot of accidents all the time and he
says well I'm a safe driver and you know
I won't get an accident I said I'm not
worried about your driving I'm worried
about the other people I'm worried about
the other people crashing into you and
then my insurance won't cover anything
and
and he says no I'll just pay for it it's
like no you can't even pay the 75 a week
for your half of the of the daycare how
are you going to pay okay hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold on this whole
thing is a mess
it is a mess okay whole thing's a mess
as I said um listen to me listen to me
carefully and what I'm going to say is I
would not say this in an abusive
situation but I'm saying this to you
okay so I don't want everyone who's
married in is in a messy situation to
extrapolate there what I'm about to say
to you to their world I'm just saying
this to you
you are getting the world you allow
I know okay and if here's what I want to
communicate
um I think things are funny that my wife
didn't ask does not think is funny
and
I also have a couple of ticks like uh
not like the bugs but like yeah I have
some like vocal tics
and for whatever reason whenever there's
a sound I instantly mimic it
so if there's like a thing in the drawer
and he goes all right I'll just be
across the house and I'll be like and it
just comes out I don't know why I wish
it didn't but it
so for the first X number of years my
wife was always saying stop or what
and then she had a realization she's
just making herself tired and miserable
this is the guy I married and I love him
he's hilarious I wish he wouldn't make
that joke at the dinner table but most
of the time he's awesome and I think
it's weird that he makes those noises
but no I think it's endearing because I
see what I'm saying so if you're not
gonna leave and you love this guy
stop carrying it around
because you're comparing your life to
him you're frustrated and it's just
adding to the already really difficult
challenge you have of being a working
mother with a autistic son severely
autistic son and a husband that y'all
are still splitting bills with again
very we're not legally married that's a
thing we're not legally married we live
together
so oh my gosh lead with that Marie move
out what are you doing move out because
the lease the lease isn't up until July
cool what's your what's your soul worth
what's your sanity worth
um is it worth a couple of months I
wasn't if I wasn't said dang poor then
that's why I said if I just hold out
until July but I don't know how to but
you know one I wanted to see if I could
get if I could get it through to him to
just grow up he's Hey listen he's not on
the phone so I he he's on the phone it's
like we can't talk I'm talking about him
is not a good use of our time okay I can
only talk about you
and so too how do I how do I
you probably
zero get that out of out of out of your
world there will be a whole lot of
crying period
there'll be a lot of heartbreak a lot of
the same way he's always reacted he's
gonna do that again times more that's
really scary to me okay if you're not
safe you need to leave now
I don't believe you
he's never laid his hands on me he's
gotten pretty damn close hadn't he
no he just yells a lot and but the thing
is we only fight like every once every
six months Marie the last the last time
was about four months ago and what
why
I don't know I don't know what's wrong
with me I don't know how to I don't know
there's nothing wrong obviously
obviously there is because there's not
so cut and dry when I look at it from
the outside I know you can hear yourself
Talking listen Marie you have a picture
of what you wanted this thing to look
like
yes and I thought when I had two kids it
was gonna look like this and I was gonna
have a partner that was in it with me we
were gonna live here we're gonna go to
Astros games we're gonna do all this
stuff
and it's not
and the sooner you can choose reality
and live out of that reality instead of
this fantasy that you're killing
yourself duct taping together
with tape and string and wire and wood
you're doing whatever you can to keep
this thing patched up
you gotta choose reality and I'm not
even I even think y'all can salvage this
he's gonna have to make some very
significant changes what I often find in
this exact moment
is you have hot yell at him
you have made demands in the middle of
fights you have you've never sat down
over a meal with a typed out piece of
paper and said here's what I need
and if you are choosing to not help me
meet these needs you are choosing for us
to be over
I hope you don't make that choice but
that choice is yours to make
and then when the conversation starts oh
you're just
cool old Marie you're right this is new
Marie
and this is from this day forward
I gotta have help with my kid and I know
that I'm asking you to get a new job in
the daytime I am
and I'm asking you to get up in the
morning and help with diapers or
breakfast or whatever you need help with
in dropping off at school and be a part
of his life
and go get your own parental ABA
training so that you know how to deal
with a kid who's severely autistic
because it's hard
and he's probably not going to do it
he has no incentive to right
and I go back to the original thing like
why in the world would he do anything
differently than what he's doing why
would he get a driver's license he has a
car
but right now right this moment you can
get off the phone and call the insurance
company and cancel the insurance
foreign
how do I get my name off of the
registration then
because like
it's your car
I know I've thought about that I've told
him that too and then he called me
greedy
and I said like I'm the one who is
paying for all the stuff on this car you
don't even have a license and then he
called me greedy and he also called me
greedy when I asked for
um you know my hat for his half of the
daycare
I he's employed full-time I haven't
played part-time while I'm in school I
can't why would he give you money
why I don't I
because that was our agreed that was our
agreement and it had been
and they have been going like that until
August and then he called your bluff
well he had been paying and then August
happened and I don't know what happened
in August but oh the the daycare cost
went up and then suddenly he couldn't
afford it it's like yeah because I can
you make twice as much as I do how do
you not afford it
and then the day just goes on
yeah
I'm heartbroken for you Marie because I
know you're trapped I I know you it
feels like you're trapped you're not
travel you feels like you are and I get
that and I also think you love this guy
you probably don't like him but I think
you love this guy or you love the idea
of him and what y'all could have had
together what y'all might still have
together
but I also hear an exhausted mother of a
special needs kid and an exhausted
mother who's trying to go to school and
to work
and he's tired of also carrying a third
kid that's now got a missile that he's
unlicensed to be driving
hauling around Houston Texas which does
not have a bunch of great drivers in it
no no if there's um that's where I grew
up there's at least there's like two to
three accidents right outside of our um
our neighborhood every day two hours of
the day all of that all of that is a
proxy
for one thing
is Maria gonna care about is Marie gonna
care about Marie
the way she's trying to care for
everybody else
and until you get there
you're just gonna walk around frustrated
because nobody's going to change because
there's no reason to change you're not
gonna leave you're gonna figure out how
to get a couple of more shifts and pay
for it you're gonna end up getting done
with school and making a bunch of money
you're gonna take care of the kids
Nothing's Gonna Change
I know and that's so awful to me that's
why I called yeah because I hate that it
feels like nothing is going to change
and I don't that's what I thought of how
do I change it just one way take that
unfortunately take the no no I don't I
don't think that's the first step I
think the first step is
doing whatever you can to it's the same
as I do with my kid
just like I said it earlier okay
just like I said earlier
um
here is what I need
I need a partner that wakes up with me
in the morning
and helps with the kid
I need a partner who
uh helps with bedtime
I need a partner who will get trained
and help me out
I need someone who has a plan for are we
going to get married or not
someone who because I want to get
married so that we can create a
long-term safe life together that I
don't know you're not just going to take
off on oh just all in all and all in all
I need someone sometimes I need to leave
and go be with my friends because I'm
working like crazy
all of those things you got to spend
some time with you writing down here's
what I need
and these are different than wants
here's what I need
and then he gets to choose are you in or
you out
you've got to come up with your or what
statement I will never tell somebody to
leave unless they're being abused okay
you've got to come up with your or what
statement and you've got to own the
weight of it Marie I won't take that
from you
if he doesn't do these things or what
are you gonna do
that's the cross you have to bear if you
want to stay I'll be here and I'll talk
you through it if you want to go I'll be
here and I'll talk you through it
but he's got no incentive to change Zero
none
because you're carrying everything
as someone who spent her whole life
being a peacekeeper making sure
everybody else's needs were taken care
of and everybody else was happy and
everybody else liked you
hope and prayer for you is at some point
you say I'm worthy of that Same Love
it has to start with me
you're worth being well Marie
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as you wrap up today's show um
man this band is named after something
that Kelly doesn't have
the band's called heart and the song is
Magic Man it goes like this cold late
night so long ago and I was not so
strong you know a pretty man came to me
never seen eyes so blue you know I could
not run away seemed we'd seen each other
in a dream it seemed like he knew me he
looked right through me yeah
try to understand
I'm a magic man listen if anyone tells
you in a bar they're a magic man run run
God Almighty see you soon love y'all